I told all the head of departments I
wanted the actors to go through the same
Journey they went through
chronologically in the same condition so
I told Felix FZ not to use green screen
because I didn't want the actors to be
distracted by that I prepared the actors
for months for this film and and I told
him that we were going to shoot the film
as if it was a documentary so it was all
about preparing the film to allow the
actors to go through the Journey the
same Journey going through the same
emotions the fear the the the the hungry
because they went through a street diet
the cold because we shot in real
locations in order to allow the audience
to leave the journey with them